he did not fat-faced you I was Issa Rae
is the creator of the new show insecure
but before she was on HBO she spent
years building a fan base
thanks to her YouTube series awkward
black girl AMA is that you do have a
head actually I'm thinking about ending
things with morals I'm sorry hold it
where it sat down with Rae after a
screening of her new show to talk about
bringing her ideas to primetime what
were you trying to say with with this
program and what with that with the show
I wasn't kind of like make a declarative
statement or hang anybody over the head
with the message but I just wanted to
show you know a slice of life and sort
of normalized blackness it was just like
oh that's a part of your life and you're
still worried about like oh I gotta pay
these bills or all this dude is still on
my couch or you know it's just just
regular people who happen to be black
talk about about the music in the in
this series I mean there's a lot of good
stuff I mean even in the pilot that I
mean it's just it's also very
meticulously put together and how
important that was to you to get right
to me even just before I even knew like
what the show was gonna be I knew that I
wanted a soundtrack that would feel like
it could be the soundtrack to somebody's
life I wanted female rappers I loved
raunchy rap like that's something that I
grew up on in the building Iowa
and I just wanted that to be reflected
in the show our current showrunner he
was a huge hip-hop head and Melina our
director comes from the world of music
videos so music was extremely important
to her and she's the reason why we got
Solange's our music is a yeah I heard I
heard the salon was your supervisor yes
and it was amazing and like actually
acted like an employee which was crazy
it was like hey so long as we can't do
these tracks I'll get you right away you
know and I was like salon when there's
what you don't even have to do you have
to be here yeah but she took the job
really seriously and it was great about
you know facilitating relationships with
up-and-coming artists Oh shoddy its
mother
thank but no one cares because I'm not
having a party cuz I'm feeling sorry for
my yeah yeah in terms of the raps that
that you write for the show where does
that come in in the writing process like
do you do you write a rap and then say
okay maybe this goes in the scenery read
a scene and then it kind of becomes yeah
right scene and then just write a first
draft rap or if the other if we're in
the other we have obviously writers room
and so if they had an episode they would
usually just leave it blank which was I
wish they would make it a template there
when I see so right to rap here and
Larry and I co-wrote the broken
meant I was gonna that was gonna be my
next question that's where this uh where
did Brooke and come from uh well
the the cuff but the concept broken
came about from me telling me
about how one of my best friends and I
talked about like it actually had a
conversation about that and discuss like
Oh My Jesus Percy is broken and
we talk in like voices for our vagina
it's sounding like Marge Simpson mix of
Marge Simpson / - we did it's like if a
guy comes through we'd be like my
was like mmm I thought was telling Larry
that just getting in the process of
getting to know each other and he was
like oh that's going in there I don't
care what we write about but that that's
gonna be a scene oh wait a minute so
you're trying to tell me you went all
the way to Daniel's house and like at
all
I didn't even go inside up you
gotta say the one all-day snow but by my
broken becae for nothing like all that
drama for z-bo dick did you plug it it
wasn't for nothing no like it wasn't
even about Daniel it was about me
so tell me things are gonna go okay
first for every sin Molly I'm worried I
think I eat them all you know sperms
that are just like you know they can
keep it real with each other and you
kind of know that they'll be friends
they they make her see each other out um
but it's always gonna be out a lot it's
like sisters
yeah is it based on any of your real
friendships is there somebody that Molly
is based on can't some advice on you or
no dad no not apply anybody close nobody
I'm missing no it's not big it's it's
the combination thanks but yeah I mean
you're still 29 you got one more year
it's you're right I know
I don't have time for the
anymore wait what are you using I'm
breaking up with him tonight you talk
about la like it almost feels like a
character in the show like I'm gonna
grow up there correctly hurry yeah so
like you know talk about making putting
me like your la in your show um it was
that was another thing that was
important just because it's it's always
been depicted in in other movies and
films like that area south LA or even
South Central is always like oh you
going into the hood now you got to get
shot or there's you know hella gangs and
it's just always like an adventure of
misadventure and that's just not what I
know it to be I know that there's a
history there but you know there's a
fluence and there's poverty and there's
you know upper-middle class middle class
and we all just mention this to section
enriching culture and it's so diverse
yeah I was ever saying it does that come
in there in the writing room in the
writers room to where you you're talking
about ass eating like well this would
happen at this restaurant or you know at
this location or whatever you know does
that also become part of the the story
itself it did it a lot of the
discussions happen within the writers
room but it was also harder because not
everybody was from LA you think we'd
have to go out and kind of explore and
be like oh that's right I don't forgot
about this place we go here and there's
so many places that we didn't get to go
to that hopefully we'll be able to go on
to